i am here with my culinary partner in
crime it's chef paular valdes
and it is time for something very
special i'm excited we're a little
nervous and thrilled beyond because
our cookbook is out today
[Music]
[Applause]
it's something that we've worked on for
so long and it's so surreal when it
actually just like doesn't belong to you
anymore and it's
out there and that was the whole point
we made it for now it belongs to all of
you exactly but it really is a labor of
love and it's very intimate there's 300
of our personal photographs in there as
well as professional photography but
it's just a really nice blend it's about
life and being in the kitchen and
there's no pretension so that's exciting
[Applause]
we also have three guests here today who
will be tasting some dishes from the
book please welcome back to the show our
official taster and dear friend kareem
hi friends
and please say hello to our new friends
stephanie and don
i love that call up a chair and let's
start making one of my favorite recipes
from the book i mean we love them all
but we chose three today that we thought
might kind of work for you guys in the
audience to get a glimpse of what's
inside this book and we're going to
start with oh it says it's called my
favorite shredded beef need i stay more
let's do it
so this uh recipe is kind of a cross
between like a tina del res or a ropa
vieja and you're gonna start with some
chalk over here and i seasoned it with a
little bit of salt
and a little bit of paprika
and some black pepper
and then we're going to start by
browning the meat this is really where
you start to develop that flavor and
texture and texture from the get-go so
we have some avocado oil over here and
we're going to put the meat down we have
some raw seasoned meat you're not
cooking it all the way through you're
just giving it like a beautiful brown
winter coat basically oh a brown winter
colored brown winter coat a toasty
winter coat
and we actually have some pre-browned
meat that we did a little earlier and
i'm actually just going to add the other
guys now they're all browned and add
that to the pot
we toasted some
mexican oregano
some human which drew i know you love i
love cumin so much so we're gonna add in
we have some onions
some celery some carrots
some
garlic and some jalapenos now if you
don't like things spicy you can have the
quantity or you can leave them out
so we're going to saute those vegetables
you want the vegetables to start to
caramelize to get a little bit of color
because again that's gonna be where the
flavor is okay
so
you're gonna let that go for about eight
to ten minutes it's getting nice and
soft and then you're gonna add
your
tomatoes those are canned tomatoes um
but you can also use crushed tomatoes if
you like we added some water as well
drew yep to thin it out a little bit and
create those juices that it's going to
marinate and oh my god it smells so good
already and then the last thing you're
gonna add to this is actually um we just
tied up some cilantro stems so the
leaves we actually save for later when
we're garnishing but the stems have a
ton of flavor we're gonna pack those in
and then i threw in the cloves and the
bay leaves
and all you're going to do to that pot
basically is bring it up to a boil
and then just park it just lower it down
to simmer you're going to cover it
and let it go it's going to take a
little bit two and a half hours a nice
slow cook look at this nice
the scent is i i this is one of my very
favorite dishes it's just it's a total
crowd pleaser
so do we've cooked the beef basically to
the point where you can shred it with
two forks two and a half hours three
hours
and you're just gonna take two forks
and start shredding
and then the other trick that we like to
do and this is a little bit of an extra
step but i love doing this with a lot of
like my stewson stuff is actually taking
the vegetables that we cooked um
in the pot over there and pureeing it
because that gives the sauce a really
wonderful mouth feel it's like so much
richer so much more comforting and it
thickens it in a really nice way too it
just has a better texture without adding
more fat to it you know it's sort of
it's the gift that keeps on giving so
you just pour that back into the pot
and then we still have some vegetables
from earlier
that have been cooked but we didn't
puree so that's more texture oh my gosh
i'm like can we just eat it
we're gonna eat it right now oh my god
it smells really really good are you
guys ready over there
i was gonna say that it freezes up
really nicely but we never have
leftovers um obviously you can also take
a taco shell and put it in there
and just make these great classic kind
of street tacos that are just
juicy do a little pickled onion
a little creme fraiche or sour cream
oh my god i'm really salivating now okay
um and squeeze a little lime onto it do
a little cilantro
um pilar makes things beautiful and
decorative with some radishes
um which is a really really clever thing
all right so
kareem
and stephanie and dawn are you ready to
try this with us yeah i thought you
would never have it
right i know
what do you think
i see nodding
[Laughter]
a meat beef starburst like so much
flavor
so soft it's very soft it's very it's
got so much flavor in it um
we can't get all this right
and as demonstrated
it is a one pot dish and this is
actually our beautiful cookware and the
truth is we just came out with a slow
cooker for this very exact same reason
as the dutch oven one pot
is good for busy people who have a lot
on their plate as it is
to cook beautiful dishes with all in a
contained space and way so
i'm so glad that we're eating
[Music]